Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie! This week's Game
of Thrones video is going to be all about
Tyrion, Daenerys and what's going on in the
East when we pick up with Season 6. We're
mostly caught up with the books. And the stuff
that's been filming that we know about that's
going on in westeros Is really super spoilery
so it seemed like a pretty good time to talk
about horses and dragons just careful for
spoilers for everything this happened on the
show so far and everything that the show has
done from the books and new round of the giveaway
starts now it's a a copy of a knight of the
seven kingdoms either Kindle or paperback
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video so here
we go get you with the nearest first she's
been taken by the Khalasar we don't know who
but in the books she's taken by Khal Jaqho
who basically took the largest portion of
Khal Drogo's goes forces after he died off
during season one thing about the Dothraki
is that it's all about survival of the fittest
so anytime one Khal dies another will swoop
in to try and take all the men the horses
the resources so that's for Khal Jaqho comes
in and it seems like the show has cast his
character they they haven't confirmed it so
still speculation but of all the big Dothraki
characters that you can do after Khal Drago
Jaqho was at the top of the list so that the
nearest is going to win the loyalty of the
Dothraki which she definitely needs she definitely
needs those forces she's going to have to
work with Khal Jaqho there's a number of different
ways she could do that she could win the respect
of all the Dothraki using her dragons crazier
she could just marry him that would pry be
the easy route to go so this pilot the shows
can end up doing just because the story all
about sacrifice the nurse would have to sacrifice
her freedom in getting married to him but
as rent adjustment the nurses storyline she's
largely subdued Marine so why would she need
those Dothraki forces what you need a large
army isn't really expressed an interest in
going to west roast yet she seems relatively
entrenched with her goal of pacifying slavers
Bay and that is where new problems arise need
to have. In various that are Marine so in
any big problems dated David arise they're
going to try and handle you things like daily
governance health problems like the blood
he flux and then you have other forces from
slavers Bay rearing their heads again is already
visited and pacified Astapor and then you
and Kai but she left like she took her army
and she went to Marine so the wise masters
of young Kai rear their heads again in the
books so they might bring them back on the
show as well and use them as an opposing force
use them is like the Bolton's of the East
you know your big battles with Bolton's going
on in west roast during season six I think
something similar will be going on in the
East and that's where like the wise masters
the other combined forces of slavers Bay come
in so tier and in various into nearest consequently
will have to find a way to defend Marine against
internal threats as well as external and in
then you have the health read like the blood
he flux the show hasn't really done a whole
up with that the semi just toss that aside
her or mention something in passing sometimes
when the show skips plots like the leader
have a good character mention something or
mention of the character but you won't actually
see on screen the blood he flux is just what
they called dysentery in a song of ice and
fire so very ugly very disgusting ailment
to get the also call it the pale mayor so
people are terrified of mounting the pale
mayor that is why it is so important to teach
your children to wash their hands but regardless
of of how these threats all converge. Taveras
will probably learn about the threat first
the engineers will have to hear about something
consequently because she's way further north
in the East shall be closer to the Dothraki
see should be somewhat removed from the action
for little while one of the good things about
flying on a dragon is that they go really
far really fast though because the start of
each season usually picks up in the moments
after though the preceding finale at the the
true God still going to be out of commission
for a little while at least for the first
episode are so there are reports of the Dothraki
people going to Northern Ireland to film scenes
that doesn't necessarily mean they're going
to west roast they might be using that is
a double for the Dothraki see so I think there
will be a big Dothraki battle eventually but
either it will be like a bunch of different
callous just warring with each other Oral-B
relative to this Marine plot even west of
the it's going to be a while before to nurse
Marshall's a large army and takes them to
west roast remember they did pretty much said
going to be eight season so I think they're
going to push a lot of the biggest action
but the biggest battles with the nurse in
west roast to season eight the weird thing
though is that they they changed a lot of
filming location so they been filming a lot
of scenes together like and in close proximity
to other characters sees the don't necessarily
crossover it is a certain locations double
for multiple places just just for example
the Riverland stuff happens in Northern Ireland
as well as the stuff up in your winter fell
in the North lassies and they also use Spain
for both the nurses internal seems like when
she was inside as well as the door and scenes
were using when you hear about multiple characters
in the same place is just one of the course
of production but let me know in the comments
you in my bequest of you guys do you think
that the nearest is going to have to deal
with the Dothraki Civil War or do you think
that the Dothraki are gonna be fighting someone
else I feel like they want to keep the nearest
interior Taveras storylines just a little
bit separate so they can do that the tearing
first Laurel and Hardy think they can give
them a lot of really good scenes together
just by themselves and digging into nearest
like a separate challenge for her to deal
with on her own up to this point each time
to nurses have like a really big problem she
has had people to lean on advisers to lean
on so I think they want to take that crutch
away for little while just compounding that
I also think they want to take the crutch
of drogue gone away just for a little bit
to just preloaded mind you I don't need to
get a pension for the entire season that will
be blasphemous but just address some of the
other stuff that's been going on that they
been filming a lot of northern stuff in and
around the Bolton especially rumors a big
main characters coming back in Ramsey Bolton
doing something really terrible to them as
all wild speculation and is super spoil re-but
if you want to talk about armies is totally
okay just please use spoiler tag's in the
comments just the thought is is that the gonna
do a similar version of what they did to show
Marine in episode nine except it's going to
be Ramsey Bolton burning someone alive is
supposed to be someone we love and we haven't
seen in a couple seasons everybody theory
craft now and why does Reddick congratulations
to last week's giveaway winner Ethan Hodge
I hope I'm I'm saying your name right you
win a copy of a knight of the seven kingdoms
please private message me on the back and
my channels like get your contact info and
if for some reason like things get crazy this
week and I don't have time to do a Q&A video
on us the giveaway winner whenever I post
my next game of thrones video so no worries
we are getting dangerously close to Jessica
Jones and if you don't know anything about
that all at a link for the trailer in the
description is going to be bad ass it's the
next big marble Netflix series white as way
for that to post it just in case you haven't
seen like bike giant Magog game of thrones
playlist of all the bonus videos that don't
click here it is like everything going all
the way back to season four and you can click
here for the Jessica Jones trailer videos
thank you so much for watching, everybody
let's high five and I'll see you guys tomorrow!